[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir au harcèlement
salle gros petit minus planche à pain
nous avons tous entendu ces insultes
d'apparence inoffensive dans les cours
de collège et de lycée
mais quand elles deviennent répétitives
et qu'elles ciblent un enfant en
particulier cela devient du harcèlement
et à l'ère d'internet et des réseaux
sociaux ces attaques peuvent prendre une
dimension dramatique
le problème c'est que tout se passe sur
le téléphone de l'enfant loin du monde
des adultes
alors comment prévenir les dérives du
harcèlement trois invités ce soir pour
en parler
karina jégou vous êtes conseillère du
centre académique dead aux écoles et aux
établissements de versailles caroline
jézéquel vous êtes adjudante à la
brigade de prévention de la délinquance
juvénile et sandrine kessler vous êtes
coach spécialisé dans l'accompagnement
des victimes de harcèlement est membre
intervenante de l'association marron la
main tendue bonsoir mesdames dans son
lit selon sandrine keszler qu'est ce qui
caractérise le harcèlement alors le
harcèlement c'est une violence répétés
continue c'est un phénomène qui devient
très vite lourd sur la tête des victimes
ça se passe souvent en bandes avec un
leader bien souvent et puis des des
personnes autour que l'on appelle des
suiveurs ou pas involontairement pas
d'accord c'est forcément une bande
contre une personne isolée
ou si on peut harceler plusieurs
personnes à la fois ça peut être c'est
souvent une bande a souvent une personne
ou plusieurs voilà ce qui caractérise le
la façon de faire en fait c'est souvent
la peur l'envi d'appartenance voilà une
bande et chacun finalement dans une
bande a peur un de l'un ou de l'autre et
même le chef de bande je dirais peut
avoir peur aussi de ne plus être chef de
bande de se retrouver isolé comme chacun
d'entre eux peuvent se avoir aussi peur
de se retrouver seul donc l'effet
d'appartenance est très important on en
parlera juste après carwin jézéquel sur
le plan pénal
c'est un délit c'est c'est de la
délinquance en fait pour vous tout à
fait depuis la loi de 2014 en fait le
harcèlement scolaire est devenu
justement un délit donc c'est puni d'un
an de prison
si effectivement ces commis par un
mineur justement la peine sera divisé
par 2 donc ce qui passera six mois et
puis on puisse cette peine peut être
aggravée si ces commis par un par
internet ou par téléphone
donc le cyber harcèlement à graver tout
à fait c'est puni de deux ans de prison
pour pour un mineur tout à fait enfin
vise part de la baisse du coût pour un
mineur pour un majeur si ça majeur qui
commet le harcèlement c'est deux ans de
prison et donc ça passe à un an pour
mineurs si c'est un mineur qui commet
une infraction
karina jégou ce ça concerne des enfants
des adolescents
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
observez est ce que ce sont il ya des
profils particuliers
alors je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
parler de profits ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on a à chaque fois des enfants qui
ont une mauvaise image d'eux mêmes
souvent ça commence comme ça qu'ils ont
envie de s'intégrer effectivement un
groupe et
les relations ayant du mal à se nouer
souvent voilà le mécanisme dürer sinon
peut s'enclencher
et vous vous parlez
au corps enseignant pardonnez-moi de
cela qu est ce qu est ce que vous leur
dites alors c'est vraiment un axe déjà
deux prises par une des priorités
l'académie de versailles du département
des yvelines en particulier est
effectivement s'adresse à tous les
enseignants de la maternelle jusqu'au
jusqu'au lycée et après post bac avec
l'idée de leur apprendre à reconnaître
les signaux du harcèlement voilà on y
est déjà à la maternelle dès la
maternelle alors parlé de harcèlement
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué parce
qu'on n'est pas dans la volonté de nuire
forcément mais en tout cas on peut
commencer à travailler sur les relations
entre jeunes développer les compétences
psychosociales et part en revanche sur
la fin du primaire et puis le collège
là on est vraiment dans le coeur de
cible malheureusement des actions et
après sur le cyber harcèlement pas mal
aussi pour le lycée saint john kessler
il n'y a pas d'âge minimum alors se
développe c'est vrai qu'on à
l'adolescence on a 14 15 ans comme âge
un petit peu critique alors souvent ça
commence enfin ça commence ça commence
très tôt ça commence très tôt on peut
pas parler de harcèlement effectivement
on parle de brimades de ci de là alors
c'est vrai que c'est bien d'en parler au
petit avec des interventions et des
schémas des jeux voilà un bonhomme comme
j'ai vu cet après midi avec catherine
verdier la vice-présidente un bonhomme
sur lequel est dessiné sur une grande
feuille et on leur fait mettre des post
it à quel endroit sur la tête sur le
coeur sur les jambes pour signifier quoi
du côté du harceleur du côté des
victimes du côté des des gens qui
regardent aussi et on se rend compte
effectivement ça parle quand même sur
sur les petits après c'est vrai que sur
des 6e 5e c'est très intéressant parce
qu'on peut avoir un vrai échange avait
que moi je le fais l'intérieur sous le
mode des changes donc c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup qu'est ce que c'est que
pour vous le harcèlement qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est ce que vous avez fait déjà
qu'est ce que vous avez mis en place
qu'est ce qui est possible qu est-ce qui
est pas possible
donc c'est vrai que c'est une période un
peu charnière entre je dirais 6e 6e 4e
c'est un moment intéressant en tout cas
pour s'en préoccuper et les sensibiliser
et on rappelle que donc l'association
dont vous êtes membre marion la main
tendue a été monté par la maman d'une
jeune fille qui avait 13 ans marion donc
sont effectivement dans cet âge là et
qu'il a malheureusement mis fin à ses
jours donc c'est un sujet très sérieux
appuis caroline jézéquel vous vous
rendez aussi dans les
dans les collèges dans les lycées dans
même dans l'école primaire en fait non
une unité spécialisée de la gendarmerie
on est si personnel à la bpdj brigade de
prévention de la délinquance juvénile et
en fait on intervient donc de la
primaire jusqu'au lycée et en primaire
on leur parle pas du harcèlement enfin
de l'autre voilà où est ce que ça peut
faire mal et c'est vrai qu'on se rend
compte qu'ils l'ont très bien compris et
puis même déjà vous parlais tout à
l'heure au début avant d'annoncer le
débat voilà les insultes alors souvent
effectivement c'est ce qu'on entend
c'est pour rire mais oui mais on rigole
et puis c'est vrai que bah quand ça dure
dans le temps c'est ce que je leur
explique guy - imaginez on m'appelait le
pij trompe pas ce que je suis en bleu
quand j'en étais quand je viens les voir
en cm2 gib.a peut-être que la première
fois je vais rigoler mais peut-être qu'à
force et ben ça va me faire mal au coeur
donc on essaie de leur faire prendre
conscience de ça et puis au collège
comme disait comme vous disiez c'est
vrai que c'est un échange qui est
intéressant parce que voilées ils
comprennent très bien qu'on prenne
oui comprennent tout à fait ou alors
souvent de pareilles c'est à dire c'est
un peu le même genre de phrase qu'on
retrouve c'est oui mais on s'amuse mais
ça m'a aussi dans le même sens mains
voila je le chaman un peu je mets des
petites claques derrière la tête mais
lui me fait pareil voilà enfin annoncé
mais ils savent très bien et vous sentez
quand vous intervenez comme ça que
certains sont de potentiels harceleur
épique lisait sur leurs visages qu'ils
prennent conscience et qu'ils ne feront
pas ou est ce que vous arrivez à sentir
sarr qui prennent conscience je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas on arrive
effectivement détecté dans certaines
classes ont à dire les leaders ce qui
pourrait entraîner les autres ça on le
voit assez rapidement karina jégo oui
alors nous on n'intervient pas auprès
des élèves si ce n'est auprès des
ambassadeurs lycéens conforme
effectivement au niveau de la lutte
contre le harcèlement
mais c'est vrai qu'on voit des ambiances
de classe quand il nous arrive
d'intervenir auprès des ambassadeurs on
sent bien que certains posent des
questions très précises en termes de
risque wallach mais qu'est ce que je
risque signe les insultes ça laisse des
traces vendée on est bon on sait bien
que c'est un sujet sensible et que
certains camps et prennent conscience
des conséquences
en tout cas sans une catin justement on
se sait harceleur on peut se penser
harceleur
on sait qu'on va trop loin parfois je
suis pas sûr qu'on sache qu'on aille
trop loin
et puis si l'on fait rire l'ensemble du
groupe
si l'on arrive à mener un groupe en tout
cas on se sent fort donc c'est vrai que
pour quelqu'un qui a envie d'être un
petit peu plus
mais un peu plus leader voilà d'être un
peu plus en avant qu'un autre ça ça va
lui faire plaisir
en tout cas il sait qu'il peut le faire
parce que les autres le suivent
la complication c'est surtout après pour
les pour les suiveurs c'est vrai que
c'est une situation un peu compliquée
pour eux ils arrivent ils font alors mal
gérée malgré eux en fait ils sont là ils
peuvent être harceleur malgré eux
effectivement ils pourront fonctionner
au par le rire et c'est seydou les
changes que l'on a avec eux en leur
disant est ce que d'après vous vous êtes
vous êtes harceleur aussi où est ce que
vous êtes suiveurs actif ou passif
comment ça se passe comment vous le
ressentez alors souvent c'est non non
pas du tout et bien quand on fait la
démonstration
oui ça peut l'être est-ce qu'on est on
voit souvent ces clichés de harceleur
harceler est ce que c'est vrai on a
souvent la personne un peu faible
l'enfant un peu isolé aux lunettes etc
est ce que est ce que c'est vraiment
finalement ça peut concerner tout le
monde tout le monde peut être victime
finalement par les différences sont
tellement je pense que tout le monde
paie du team ce signe qu'ils sont aux
normes c'est à dire qu'un enfant qui ne
dénote pas dans un quartier ou dans une
école en changeant peut très bien ne
plus être ne plus correspondre aux
normes attendues dans cet établissement
et finalement se retrouver en proie du
coup aux moqueries effectivement là il
peut devenir une victime potentielle
alors que ça se passait très très bien
auparavant
malheureusement les clichés ont un peu
attendu en mai
parfois nous nous facilite pas non plus
la tâche par exemple dans la mesure où
effectivement parfois on peut avoir de
très très bons élèves qu'ils soient
arcelor par exemple d'accord on a plus
souvent des mauvais élèves de la classe
qui va qui va receler qu'est ce que ça
change finalement peut-être quand
l'adulte va le voir si jamais il ya une
suspicion de harcèlement on l'abordé
différemment c'est vrai qu'on aura
peut-être plus de scrupules en étain du
candidat pourtant il de bon élève
alors c'est une réaction qu'on peut
avoir effectivement rendront la demande
en moindre souvent mais c'est vrai qu'on
avait beaucoup beaucoup on était
beaucoup
oui sur des clichés et des images
auparavant car lynch avec elle là dessus
sur vous quand vous rencontrez les
élèves
effectivement les profils sont
finalement fou oui puis comme comme vous
disiez c'est vrai que ça peut très bien
être les premiers de la classe et pas
forcément leur souvent on pense aux
clichés effectivement duroux par exemple
parce que ç'a toujours été je sais pas
pourquoi mais depuis des décennies ça
dure la personne qui est un petit peu
d'embonpoint par exemple mais c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve comme je disais tous les
profils et
il n'ya pas ne peut pas dire qu'ils
aient une catégorie plus ou moins qu'ils
soient soient plus ou moins préserver ou
en tout cas le message c'est accepter
les différences c'est un passeur s'est
clairement sur la différence
essentiellement il ce travail peut être
fait par qui par les parents par vous
par toussaint par tous par les parents
préalable bien sûr en n'hésitant pas à
parler à son enfant éventuellement lui
signifiant des situations qui ne soit
pas forcément là celle de l'enfant de
dissocier d'aller lui dire bah tiens
j'ai entendu parler de ça qu'est ce que
tu en penses
qu'est-ce que tu ferais dans cette
situation j'ai entendu dire que tel
enfant on lui parlait pas il était seul
dans la cour comment tu réagis ray toi
du coup ça suscite un petit peu de
réflexion et ça permet à l'enfant de
peut-être aller
voilà faire différemment changer de
comportement si ça n'était pas le cas
donc rôle et d'éducateurs de la part des
parts tout à fait un pari en chine après
effectivement les enseignants alors
comme on explique aux enfants les
enseignants sont là pour enseigner sont
là pour encadrer
malheureusement ils ne peuvent pas tout
voir parce que les situations de
harcèlement sont bien souvent cachée aux
yeux des adultes elles sont des méfaits
qu'il ne se voit pas il n'y a que les
enfants qui savent autour or les enfants
ne disent rien par peur ça c'est un gros
problème c'est la peur il faut le
répéter c'est vrai que quand on est
enfant adolescent il ya deux mondes un
il ya le monde des enfants et le monde
des adultes sains et la frontière elle
est un scénario noir explique voilà
comme vous disiez c'est que les profs ou
les maîtresses sont là pour laurence et
lancer des choses mais sont là aussi
pour les écouter et ça c'est vraiment
important parce que c'est vrai qu'on dit
aussi que voilà le soir quand l'élève
rentrer chez lui peut-être que le les
parents sont fatigués parce qu'ils
reviennent du travail sont pas forcément
l'écoutent
voilà s'ils voient qu'il ya pas une
oreille attentive du côté des parents
d'aller en parler un autre adulte ça
peut être voilà l'infirmière le cpe en
prof avec qui s'entend bien enfin
vraiment ça c'est ne pas garder ça pour
lui en essonne avant d'en parler tout à
fait carénage et govou qui former les
enseignants faim voulait former
justement à cela
oui alors à la fois voilà on les
sensibilise sensibiliser au maximum
après effectivement
mais c'est de travailler vécu sur ce
qu'on appelle la méthode d'intérêt
commun c'est à dire comment travailler
sur le vivre ensemble travailler sur
l'empathie c'est vraiment essentiel et
on est vraiment dans un axe du projet
2020 de l'académie qui est comprendre et
agir dans le monde de demain
21e siècle c'est travailler tous
ensemble c'est accepter les différences
c'est s'enrichir finalement des
différences de l'autre et on est
vraiment en tout cas sur cet accessoire
cet objectif
et ça marche on s'aperçoit qu'ils aient
un petit peu moins de deux heures
seulement 6e
c'est la première baisse significative
depuis le temps les langues de plans de
prévention ferrer régulièrement des
enquêtes de climat scolaire alors je
pense que c'est grâce au travail engagé
notamment par la bpdj puisqu'on on pense
que les élèves ont été sensibilisés dès
l'élémentaire donc a priori ça
fonctionne voilà quand ils en ont
entendu parler il est témoin voilà les
suiveurs sont plus à même je pense de se
détacher et d'alerter les adultes c'est
effectivement c'est très compliqué quand
on est victime parce qu'on a peur parce
qu'on a montrent donc on compte
finalement sur ses élèves pour
développer leur sens ce citoyen civique
et venir et déportés six ans aux autres
ce que vous avez les ambassadeurs et
notamment les ambassadeurs ici en même
temps d'accord que vous formez mais la
difficulté c'est finalement cantonnés
dans une classe j'ai mon portable je
suis élève je reçois des messages de
harcèlement comment le prof peut le voir
c'est difficile de s qu'il a le droit de
venir de dire montre-moi concrètement
comment ça peut se passer là ça serait
rediscutée justement entre nous mais
effectivement les enseignants n'ont pas
le droit c'est un objet que privé voilà
d'entre eux privés donc effectivement on
peut pas après l'utilisation du portable
est interdite en classe de toute façon
on peut jouer là dessus
en revanche ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'informer aussi les parents c'est
finalement eux n'ont été pas conscience
aussi du développement des réseaux
sociaux des messageries instantanées
de la communication qui se sont entre
les jaunes c'est vrai qu'ils ont plein
un vocabulaire qui quand même pas
toujours très cher et on va dire
et finalement c'est comment leur faire
prendre conscience que déjà ce qu'ils
mettent sur la toile massa les traces
c'est sûr est que le simple fait
finalement de deux lacs et comme ils
disent ou deux au contraire de décrier
quelqu'un de critiquer finalement peut
avoir des répercussions lourdes
ces amplificateurs internat à oui oui en
terme de vitesse de diffusion
et puis on se rend pas compte quand on
est derrière son écran fait un simple
clic on a puni simplement simple geste
du bout des doigts et ça suffit
malheureusement a déclenché après à des
situations qui sont vraiment douloureuse
pour les enfants et les familles ça
paraît anodin 120 kessler là dessus sur
quelque chose qui serait réseaux sociaux
internes multiplient alors nombre de
clics par élève
1 vous multipliez un clic par nombre
d'élèves d'une classe nombre de classes
dans un établissement parce
qu'évidemment ça va très vite
et puis ça nous poursuit en dehors de la
classe ça vous sert suis ça veut dire
que le harcèlement ces 24 heures sur 24
il n'y a pas de répit l'enfant sort de
l'école il rentre chez lui il a toujours
son portable donc effectivement si là
encore avec lui le soir c'est dans son
lycée dans sa chambre est dû de ce fait
ça peut être toute la nuit et de la
les enfants sont très réceptifs aux à
toutes les insultes évidemment
puisqu'ils sont en pleine croissance
et c'est là les langues d'identité un
qui se crée donc c'est très difficile
pour eux quand on leur lance des
insultes de se dire non je ne sais pas
moins d'avoir le recul que nous avons
deux voilà ils ne l'ont pas donc après
c'est vrai que aux parents aussi d'être
attentif au comportement de l'enfant
un enfant qui commence à avoir mal au
ventre qui ne veut plus manger qui
s'enferme dans sa chambre qui s'isole
qui parle moins on des choses un petit
peu c'est pas toujours facile attention
parce que l'enfant est très très fort
pour masquer mais être très très
vigilant et encore une fois parler de
situations autres voilà c'est à dire tu
sais voilà j'ai entendu parler de ça moi
ça m'est arrivé point de conscience qu
effectivement les réseaux c'est
dangereux quand on met quelque chose
la photo est lié à vie on peut la
retirer part de certains a été très
compliqué on la réponse si vous voulez
retrouver quelque chose me à 10 ans va
on va retrouver donc ça les enfants pas
conscience de ça et quand vous demandez
en classe d'ailleurs qui la question
sait pas qui est un portable c'est qu'il
n'a pas de portable déjà et qui n'a pas
de n'est pas relié à des réseaux et vous
avez trois quatre cinq élèves pas plus
facile encore ça oui oui d'accord et
cela donc son
moins susceptible ils mentent ils
entendront moins longtemps les choses
voilà chez eux ils ne retrouveront pas
sa place dans le cadre de l'école on est
tout à fait quelque chose qui peut
justement les exclure le fait qu'ils
n'essaient pas de voile à un brésil
sociaux et de son plein et mines cible
finalement parce qu'ils peuvent enfin je
n'ai pas peuvent être une cible
finalement ça deviendrait du harcèlement
pas un pas cyber harcèlement du
harcèlement tout court parce que
maintenant le voilà ça c'est des admins
c'est un peu ça n'avait pas la télé
quand les années 80 je vous connais un
peu sur le mal et même baskets à la mode
il ya ça existe encore un chai entendu
ça ya pas très longtemps
ben oui mais il n'est pas du tout
habillé comme nous alors c'est
surprenant mais c'est vrai c'est fou ça
nous paraît tellement tellement anodin à
nous adultes mais en réalité ça ça
compte
d'où le travail sur la non vraiment
c'est important que vous disiez tout à
l'heure parce que voilà quand vous allez
visiter un pays vous rencontrer d'autres
cultures d'autres personnes
vous aimez tous les enfants n'ont pas
l'opportunité de dépasser un endroit
ici près de chez eux enfin et c est en
tout cas la rencontre d'autres personnes
d'autres lieux qu'est ce que ça vous
apprends qu est ce que ça vous apporte
et bien par rapport à tel enfant ça peut
être la même chose
et puis et puis peut-être que cet enfant
a eu des soucis peut être qu'il est
malade peut-être qu'il a vécu en 2d
c'est peut-être qu'il ya plein de choses
qui font que des choses auxquelles les
enfants ne pense pas forcément
et que ça nous adultes ont ils rappelé
car chez lesquels sur vous est ce que
vous rencontrez des harceleurs et quand
vous leur dites quand vous leur fait
prendre conscience de la gravité de la
situation qu'est ce qu'ils vous disent
rien ou c'est un peu compliqué parce que
du fait qu'on soit une brigade
spécialisée ont fait des auditions des
mineurs victimes d'agressions sexuelles
de maltraitance et effectivement il nous
arrive de faire des meilleurs des
victimes de harcèlement pas de harceleur
ça se fait dans les brigades dans les
unités territoriales et donc c'est plus
effectivement des victimes qu'elles ont
à faire est alors voulez vous les
trouvez dans quel état justement alors
ont personnellement j'ai fait qu'une
audition c'était
un enfant de cm2 donc par d'autres de sa
classe donc ça restait encore du
harcèlement qui était pas encore enfin
bien mis en place donc c'est vrai qu'on
a pu stopper assez rapidement parce que
c'est vrai qu'on travaille assez bien
avec l'éducation nationale on a en plus
des référents scolaires par brigades
dont qui s'occupe de chacun de plusieurs
établissements scolaires
donc c'est vrai qu'on a à me dire la
même chose en place assez rapidement
donc ça s'est assez vite éteint on va
dire mais ça se révèle assez efficace
entre la jusque là tout à fait pour les
yvelines karine jégo justement en
préparant cette émission je trouvais sur
internet des témoignages de mamans qui
en voulait aux enseignants qui en
voulait aux directeurs d'établissement
alors guidé ses pas de pointer du doigt
une profession mais quand même
est ce que les enseignants peuvent pas
être un peu plus vigilant peut-être
alors les enseignants mais ils sont en
cours de formation par rapport au
harcèlement c'est vrai que en attendant
enfin le coeur du métier effectivement
s'élancer une transmission de savoirs et
de plus en plus on va être sur la
transmission de savoir être et également
être vigilant au bien-être des enfants
c'est vraiment une on s'aperçoit et ça
c'est les études au niveau du climat
scolaire qui nous l'apprennent que
finalement pour mieux apprendre
il vaudrait mieux être dans un climat
sera ne pas avoir peur d'être insultée
ne pas avoir peur d'être frappés au
détour d'un couloir
ne serais même si c'est une petite tape
antonymes est donc finalement plus on va
avoir un climat serein au sein de la
classe au sein de l'établissement a
priori ou meilleurs vont être les
résultats donc on a tout intérêt tous
ensemble à travailler dans cette optique
un mot de conclusion pour chacune
sandrine kessler ce que vous avez envie
de dire je vous parle et qu'il faut
parler parler parler aux enfants ne pas
s'arrêter
voilà leur dire que tout peut arriver
dans la vie on fait tous des bêtises
aussi parce qu'on va pas pointer du
doigt forcément un élève et le
maltraiter pour ce qu'il a fait c'est
pas c'est pas le but et le
fonctionnement mais on discute et voilà
beaucoup beaucoup discuté avec eux et
dire qu'il ya toujours une solution que
l'on peut trouver et de dire les choses
ça c'est important de ne pas garder les
choses qui est très difficile car j'ai
un peu la même chose s'est vraiment
voilà savoir qui aura toujours un adulte
à leur écoute et même si ils ont pas
envie de se confier à l'adulte se
confier à une amie et à la fin ça va
forcément arriver à l'adulte voilà c'est
ce que là il y aura toujours voilà une
copine qui va en entendre parler et puis
forcément il y en aura toujours une qui
va voir le raisonnement de se dire au
relais faut que j'en parle d'un culte il
faut pas avoir honte un bon là ça oui
non pas la forme de la culpabilité
enlever la honte je rêve de mots c'est
l'idée effectivement de former les
jeunes à écouter et à relayer auprès des
adultes
et puis que les adultes aussi soit un
petit peu plus modélisant c'est à dire
que
finalement ce que font les adultes sur
le net ce qui les images
enfin les les mots qu'ils emploient les
uns vis-à-vis des autres cette espèce de
concurrence où on va mettre à l'écart
celui qui apparaît comme le maillon
faible où je pense que ça aussi les
jeunes ont besoin d'avoir des modèles à
ont besoin d'avoir des références et
c'est aussi à nous deux voilà pour
construire le jeu
enfin les adultes de demain je pense
qu'ils ont besoin d'avoir des adultes
solide qui soit porteur de belles
valeurs
oui le monde adulte et pas forcément
plus gentil que dans une cour de récré
donc ce qu'il faut aussi et à nous deux
voilà des plus virulentes très bien
merci à vous d'avoir participé en bas de
cet écran évidemment le numéro à appeler
et le site
donc officiel sur lequel se rendent si
jamais vous êtes que - ou victime de
harcèlement de harcèlement pardon merci
à vous et à mardi prochain pour un
nouveau débat
[Musique]